[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau à 7,8
sport le magazine est consacrée comme
vous le savez à l'actualité sportive
dans le département c'est parti pour le
sommaire handball le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli
un match de coupe d'europe entre issy
paris et norvégienne des bipeurs ce
kristiansand malgré les 4000 supporters
présents dans l'enceinte sportive les
franciliennes se sont inclinés d'un
petit but 25 à 24
plus de détails dans quelques instants
football on jouait ce week-end les 32e
de finale de la coupe gambardella vers
cinq évoluent en r 2 s'est inclinée
contre guingamp une équipe nationale 1
but à 0 à domicile
le résumé du match dans quelques
instants golf nous sommes à huit mois de
la ryder cup 2018 la compétition de golf
le plus médiatisé au monde
le rendez vous se déroulera comme vous
le savez sur les greens du golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour faire
le point sur l'organisation nous avons
rencontré le directeur du golf paul
hermitage coup de projecteur à présent
sur les principaux résultats du week-end
[Musique]
c'était le match à ne pas manquer pour
les passionnés de handball féminin ici
paris affronter ce samedi l'équipe
norvégienne des vipères ce christensen
en coupe d'europe au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour le
deuxième match organisé par le club
francilien dans la structure l'événement
attiré plus de 4000 spectateurs avantage
de jules grande ville une atmosphère des
grands soirs ce samedi 3 février au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus de 4000 spectateurs se sont
rassemblés dans l'enceinte pour assister
au match de coupe d'europe h f entre les
joueuses d'ici paris les norvégiennes de
christiane scène justement ça permet
aussi de faire découvrir aux enfants
mâles ambiance un match et puis
les joutes européennes c'est toujours
particulier parmi une cinquantaine de
norvégiens avaient fait le déplacement
pour ce choc européen comptant pour la
5e journée de la phase de groupes
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si on va gagner je pense
que c'est un match difficile je suis un
peu effrayé l'issue de la rencontre
mais j'ai l'espoir qu'on puisse le faire
un espoir récompenser les vipères ce
christiane cents s'impose d'un but dans
les dernières minutes contre les
franciliennes
score final 25 à 24 ici paris menez pour
tous le 3 buts à la mi temps
l'ambiance du vélodrome n'a pas réussi à
empêcher la remonte haddad et
norvégienne et ses démarches avec des
joueurs très expérimentés 1 une bonne
partie des joueuses de voirie par sa son
équipe de norvège dont la gardienne
l'arrière gauche a débuté la demi centre
est
elle n'a pas beaucoup réussi cette année
mais bon c'est gagner le prochain match
de coupe d'europe
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore garde
les joueuses d'ici paris se déplaceront
sur le terrain des russes de la da pour
la 6e et dernière journée de phase de
poules de coupe d'europe en cas de
qualification les lionnes pourrait
revenir pour un nouveau match européen
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dans les
prochaines semaines toujours handball
ont joué ce samedi soir le all star game
à lacq orthez l'aréna de bercy le rendez
vous réunissez les meilleurs
handballeurs du championnat de france
devant plus de dix mille spectateurs
dans la sélection française ont retrouvé
l'une des stars de l'équipe de france le
versailles et à valentin porte tout
juste revenu des championnats d'europe
était même capitaine de la rencontre on
écoute la réaction de valentin porte ça
peut plus dire j'aime bien mon équipe
ont une bonne équipe qui présentait bien
avec de bons gars on essaie d'allier
notre
on va dire le plaisir
mais rire et aussi quelque chose d'à peu
près sérieux la rencontre s'est soldée
par une victoire de la sélection
étrangère 39 à 38 pas face à la
sélection française de valentin porte on
referme cette page handball part de la
nationale 3 plaisir n'en finit pas de
surprendre le promu est encore ce lundi
à la deuxième place du championnat après
sa victoire 36 à 26 contre r5 coupigny
ce week end
un résultat qui leur permet de compter à
27 points au classement avec un bilan de
huit victoires pour 3 défaites les
plaisirs aux à pointe seulement les
longueurs du premier à saint polois en
football ont joué à ce week-end dans le
championnat de première division de
district guyancourt engrangé sa
cinquième victoire de la saison contre
le pec à 1 0 montigny le bretonneux
dernier du classement s'est imposé 3 1
contre l'équipe 3 du fc mantois enfin à
maurepas s'est incliné pour la deuxième
fois de la saison contre gargenville à
domicile et laisse filer les mureaux en
tête du championnat la 14e journée est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures
toujours en football mais cette fois ci
en nationale 3 dans le derby vinuales
mureaux se sont imposés à domicile
contre versailles lors de la 15e journée
du championnat
score final 1 à 0 après cette défaite
les versailles est promu cette saison
dans cette division reste à la troisième
place du classement
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre bobigny les premiers du
championnat
l'équipe compte six points d'avancé sur
les a's yvelinois versailles joue
également en coupe gambardella la coupe
de france des moins de 19 ans dans leur
stade de porchefontaine les versets qui
évolue en r2 ont frôlé l'exploit se sont
inclinés 1 à 0 contre guingamp une
équipe nationale le résumé du match les
images sont signés à nicolas dans pris
un poteau une transversale pour
versailles du côté des guingampais un
coup franc légèrement détournée qui
termine au fond des filets les dieux du
football ont choisi leur vainqueur pour
ce 32e de finale de coupe gambardella
organisé au stade de porsche en ted et
versez y est en manque de réussite
s'incline 1 0
le réalisme demain on a deux bars ça
s'arrange pas
ils ont eu un coup france il le met
c'est dommage mais c'est le foot on voit
qu'il n'était pas si serein que ça en
deuxième mi temps notamment surtout à la
fin où ça commençait il est dûment la
relance et eux également donc c'est
dommage on reste frustré parce que un
poteau une barre une action un peu
litigieuse à la fin on se dit que on se
dit qu'il y avait peut-être pas poste de
passer écrit l'exploit
un exploit que les fc versailles
pensionnaire de r2 pensait tenir jusqu'à
la 63e minute et ce but marqué par
guingamp l'équipe nationale qui joue
deux échelons au-dessus dé versailles et
un motif de satisfaction pour le club
qui jouait son tout premier 32e de
finale de coupe gambardella de son
histoire en est fier c'est un centre de
formation une vison entraînements tous
les jours on en prend trois enfants par
semaine c'était cette dernière semaine
et huit blessés on n'était pas au
complet à tenir parce qu'on retire mon
tournoi on a deux bars dont on est fier
je suis fier je suis fier de l'équipe
après cette désillusion versé se
concentre déjà sur d'autres objectifs
une victoire en coupe de paris une
montée en dh et versés sont à l'heure
actuelle 4e du championnat de r2 à un
point de la 2e place un mode course à
pied à présent la 37e édition du cross
de la sablière était organisée à ce
dimanche entre vire au fait la forêt de
meudon et versailles
plus de neuf cent quarante coureurs se
sont inscrits pour cet évènement ils ont
dû jouer des coudes dans la boue pour
remporter la victoire sur un parcours
vallonné cinq courses étaient au
programme dans le onze kilomètres
masculin c'est jean baptiste joliot qui
a remporté la course en 45 minutes et 37
secondes
chez les filles à blandine charvériat
s'est imposé en une heure une minute et
10 secondes
une 38e édition sera programmée l'année
prochaine avec l'objectif de dépasser à
les mille inscrits un mode ultimate à
présent ce week-end le premier tournoi
intérieur totalement féminin en ile de
france était dans la raab a été
organisée dans la ville de plaisir
baptisé à 0 tic l'événement réunit cinq
équipes pendant deux jours reportage de
quentin le frère
une première un plaisir la ville a
accueilli ce samedi 3 et dimanche 4
février un tournoi d'ultimate 100%
féminin baptisé rôti un rendez vous
organisé par le club de frisbee local
vraiment que le que le sport en tout cas
l'ultimate féminin freine sa place au
sein de ce sport qui est déjà mixte et
on souhaitait à cette occasion de
regrouper les filles et devait également
d'échanger en se regroupant tous
ensemble pour cette première édition une
cinquantaine de joueuses venues de toute
la région parisienne a répondu présent
cinq équipes ont pu être créés se sont
affrontés pendant deux jours on accepter
parce qu'assez peu de tournois féminins
en france on a du mal à en trouver
maintenant il a de plus en plus ces
dernières années notamment en indoor
parce que les équipes sont plus
restreints donc c'est plus facile en
france et beaucoup de mixte et c'est
parce que je pense qu'il n'y a pas à
cette fille pour faire des équipes des
plus grosses équipes pour la compétition
vu le succès rencontré cette année une
deuxième édition devrait être organisé
un plaisir l'an prochain pour un nouveau
tournoi planant au féminin
on ouvre une page golf 2018 année
charnière pour ce sport en france le
président de la ffg l'a répété pendant
ses voeux à la presse ce mercredi 31
janvier
en septembre la ryder cup sera organisé
pour la toute première fois dans
l'hexagone sur le parcours du golf
national à saint quentin en yvelines
quelques mois après l'open de france
les équipes travaillent sur ce dossier
depuis la désignation officielle en 2011
on écoute le président de la fédération
française de golf jean louis charon au
micro de tv 78 travail de longue haleine
chaque étape a été balisé réaliser les
investissements et le budget financier
est maîtrisée donc nous joueront gros
oui presque c'est l'épreuve la plus
grande dans mon jeune fille qu'on peut
atteindre jusqu'à 1 milliard eur ce qui
n'est pas rien donc oui on joue gros
dans ce sens là après cette année 2018
chargé la fédération française de golf
espère booster le nombre de licenciés
dans ces 678 club pour la saison
prochaine
ils sont près de 400 14000 golfeurs
inscrits à cette année on continue à
parler de la ryder cup 2018 a vu moi à
de l'épreuve nous sommes allés à la
semaine dernière au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour
rencontrer à paul hermitage le directeur
de la structure
il fait le point sur l'organisation de
l'épreuve et sur l'open de france
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images je suis avec paul hermitage le
directeur du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous sommes à
huit mois de la ryder cup pool est ce
que tout est prêt pour cette ryder cup
la réponse est non mais tout est sous
contrôle non il reste encore du travail
mais on est on est bien parti vraiment
on est évidemment en concentré la tête
bien sur les épaules pour
transforme l'essai puis réussir
l'événement tant qu'il reste encore du
travail mais ça va et ce qui reste à
faire justement by encore bien sûr des
détails tels que transports le plan de
transport les parkings des choses comme
ça il ya des petits éléments qui peuvent
bouger encore sur la planification des
travaux qu'on n'a pas annoncé anticiper
ou voulait petit souci comme ça
par rapport à tout ce qui est vente de
billetterie
la quantité vraiment le volume de
personnes qui vont venir tout ça ça
reste à confirmer donc et encore deux
trois petites choses qui peuvent bouger
mais en gros le plan est maintenant et
je dirais 90% à figer le parcours est
prêt à recevoir cette épreuve le
troisième événement mondial télévisée
oui oui le parcours nous conforte en ce
moment on a fait des gros travaux que
vous avez suivi en 2015 2016
et avec cet hiver hyper plus vieux qu'on
vit actuellement on est ravi de comment
se comporte le parcours il est toujours
ouvert en et section pied c'est assez
impressionnant quand même le travaux de
drainage comme ça a été une réussite
quand on compare nos deux autres
parcours qui malheureusement sont un
petit peu plus beau quoi il eu beaucoup
de pluie ces derniers mois ici sur la
région parisienne est ce que ça a joué
sur le terrain
oui oui énormément ça nous retarde pas
dans notre préparation
ça nous a permis même de détecter des
petits points faibles je donne un
exemple sur le parcours il ya ce qu'on
appelle des bunkers des bunkers cd
obstacle de sable convoi près des
grilles nous sont les fers ou et on en a
vu de trois quilles ans qui avait du mal
à drainer et donc on les refait
carrément là en ce moment donc ça c'est
même un bonus grâce au à la météo même
si on aimerait bien voir un peu de
soleil et un peu de sec sur le plan
sportif est ce que vous sentez que la
tension monte
est-ce que les capitaine de ryder cup
viennent ici au golf national pour
observer le terrain prendre un peu le
pouls de la compétition oui on a eu
l'avènement honnie au togo
on a commandé eu le plaisir d'avoir jim
furyk de foire maintenant
je ne suis pas au courant quand est-ce
qu'ils vont revenir mais je suis sûr
qu'ils vont revenir de façon démesurée
qu'a dit qu'il allait envoyer une
invitation à ses jours potentiel pour
jouer l'open de france veut pas dire
qu'ils vont tous venir la chesnaie open
de france loin de là donc c'est parce
que je suis en train de dire mais je
pense que leur focus est maintenant sûr
sur mieux connaître le parcours et des
installations
ceci dit
les joueurs aussi commença à mantes et
envoie une crème qui monte au dessus du
lait au niveau de l'europe il ya six
mois on se dise où là il ya une forte
équipe américaine avec tous ces jeunes
qu'est ce qu'on va faire contre eux on
avait quelques doutes mais plus
maintenant on se dirait même que
l'équilibré est tombé du côté de 0 point
l'open de france 2010 vie ce sera le
premier test pour le golf national en
vue de cette ryder cup qui sera fin
septembre ici à l'open de france et
maintenant dans la configuration à
schonach olek series avec avec
l'european tour on l'a déjà vécu et ans
et en vain et en plus on al'avantage de
travailler avec les mêmes organisateurs
les mêmes équipes qu'en qu'on est très
très très bien on s'entend très bien
donc la difficulté cette année c'est de
livrer les deux événéments dans un
timing très court c'est à dire que on à
fin juin l'open de france et fin
septembre dans le trois quatre mois plus
tard la ryder cup donc il ya une
logistique de montage des gradins
montage du chapiteau au montage de
structures qui va commencer à se jouer à
partir de fin avril sur le site
mais tout ça est bien maintenant
planifier
c'est même quelque part pour nous tous
un soulagement parce qu'on va commencer
à construire la ryder cup avant l'open
de france tandis que peut-être avec deux
différents promoteurs on aurait eu
l'open de france à démonter totalement
et à remonter totalement le
sur le plan sportif c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose est ce qu'il y
aura des français ici au golf national
pour cette ryder cup
je dirais qu'on a des espoirs peut-être
qu'on n'avait pas il ya quelques mois
maintenant je répète ce que thomasg
bjorn dit et que l'on pense tous c'est
que il va vraiment choisir la meilleure
équipe donc il y aura pas de la place
pour un français juste parce que la
ryder cup et en france du côté des
américains il y en a un qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui en ce moment
c'est tiger woods tiger woods qui est de
retour au plus haut niveau on peut le
dire elle a passé le cut
justement le week-end dernier il revient
bien il sera dans l'équipe et il revient
bien il revient je dirais même en toute
beauté
il a rajeuni pour moi je dirais qu'il a
5 ans 5 à 7 ans de moins
il est souriant ce qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir ces derniers temps on
voit bien que il prend plaisir
il est concentré il est juste dans ses
propos aussi sur ses propres actions
mais on sent une motivation alors je
sais pas si sa motivation et personnel
pour sa carrière en tant que
professionnel aussi sa motivation et
pour la ryder cup mais peu importe il
est de retour
il est là et on a tout espoir à l'avoir
au golf national pour seulement la
deuxième fois depuis qu'on existe une
ryder cup avec tiger woods c'est
forcément une ryder cup réussi alors
forcément mais c'est pas nécessaire
nécessairement qu'il est obligé d'être
là je maintenant que je vois la
puissance de cet événement
une ryder cup avec tiger woods c'est la
cerise une ride up peut sans tiger woods
c'est un événement magique
merci beaucoup paul hermitage et la
ryder cup c'est dans huit mois ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce sera du 28
au 30 septembre 2018 si vous êtes un
amateur de sensations fortes et que vous
aimez prendre de la hauteur pour défier
la gravité le reportage qui ce qui va
suivre devrait vous intéresser coup de
projecteur sur la section parcours
rebaptisé cette année freestyle gym ces
disciplines rattachée à la fédération
française de gymnastique à trouver son
origine dans la rue elle consiste à
franchir des obstacles urbains ou
naturels en réalisant à des figures dans
les yvelines un club implanté aux
clayes-sous-bois propose des cours le
montage est signée à romain respini
[Musique]
souvenez-vous c'était en 2001 les
français découvrent les yamakasi des
acrobates de rue qui défient la gravité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les figures pratiqué dans le
film ce sont transposés dans la vie
réelle aux clayes-sous-bois une section
parcours a vu le jour en 2011 pour
répondre à la demande
ici la pratique de ce sport urbain
rebaptisé fristel gym se passe en
intérieur dans un gymnase une chute pour
vous être fatal quand même parce que
vous maîtrisez pas 100% de la figure je
leur ai proposé de la prendre en toute
sécurité
des figures acrobatiques et dès lors que
la figure est acquise en intérieur
extérieur a bon goût beaucoup moins
d'accidents depuis la création de cette
section la pratique de cette discipline
connaît un franc succès au club
le nombre de licenciés est passé de cinq
adhérents la première année à une
quarantaine de pratiquants venus de
toutes les yvelines pour cette saison
2010 8
c'est notre corps c'est pas un vélo
c'est pas un équipement c'est vraiment
notre corps c'est une chute sur faute
d'accord si on doit être très rigoureux
on est très libre on apprend vraiment de
francs est capable une grosse adrénaline
quand on lance la figure il ya une
montée d'adrénaline et dès qu'on la
rentrée on pense en euros une fois les
bases maîtriser pour nancy cour le 3
heures le vendredi c'est elle brûle et
dépasse les frontières du gymnase gimme
pour pratiquer ce sport dans son lieu de
naissance la rue les pratiquants un peu
les traceurs utilise le milieu européen
et la nature pour réaliser des figures
[Musique]
on n'est pas vraiment des mechas quiz
pour ça que les gens partent en ont peur
dans la rue c'est qu'il pense qu'on se
lance comme ça et que si on se rate
c'est notre faute mais on passe beaucoup
de temps
on sait on sait de quoi on est capable
on fait quand même beaucoup de repérage
après sa lancée et c'est une phase très
importante parce que sinon
la peur prend le dessus et les
lancements en danger alors on aurait
peut-être été capable de le faire c'est
pour ça qu'on fait très attention avant
de se lancer pour marquer mouvement smc
décrit sous bois espère désormais
atteindre une centaine d'adhérents dans
les prochaines années la structure
pourrait surfer sur la dynamique de ce
sport qui vient d'être inscrit
officiellement dans la fédération
française de gymnastique
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du week
end
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda part du cyclisme
après laurence balas samedi dernier le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueille une épreuve de piste ce
dimanche avec la finale de la coupe
d'hiver pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce plateau
jean michel richefort figure locale du
cyclisme sur piste et membre de la
fédération française bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de parler de la compétition
pouvez vous nous rappeler le concept
le concept de cette coupe d'hiver c'est
la deuxième édition nous avons eu quatre
manches qualificatives en novembre
décembre 2 au mois de janvier et les
meilleurs coureurs à l'issue des quatre
manches sont qualifiés pour cette finale
et sur cette finale nous aurons deux
types d'épreuves des omniums avec trois
épreuves par catégorie et puis un grand
tournoi de vitesse donc il ya eu quatre
manches qualificatives ce que vous
disais est ce que vous avez vu des
talons éclore est-ce que c'est
l'objectif de ce type d'événement oui
cette coupe d'hiver pour vocation donc
de faire participer les meilleurs
coureurs francilien mais nous avons
accueilli 10 comités régionaux et nous
avons accueilli de très bons coureurs
de province et qui viendront bien sûr
qu'ils se sont qualifiés pour la finale
alors c'est la vocation même de cette
coupe d'hiver de déceler de jeunes
talents et il ne manque pas parce qu'il
y a des talents et notamment des talents
yvelinois des talents sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines et on fonde
beaucoup d'espoirs lors de cette finale
sur deux cadets notamment du vélo club
de montigny le bretonneux celio l'air et
puis à roanne l'ouvrier et ça leur
permet également de se juger sur une
piste olympique devant des spectateurs a
bien sûr c'est toujours très intéressant
de se transcender devant des spectateurs
et puis également lorsqu'on est jeune
devant des coureurs beaucoup plus
confirmés bien sûr nous avons des séries
des jeunes des minimes des cadets des
juniors des très bons juniors et puis
des premières catégories qui ont déjà
parcouru qui ont couru sur des épreuves
internationales nous aurons la présence
des militaires qui sort des six jours de
berlin et qui est le champion de france
de demi-fond par exemple et puis de très
bons coureurs nationaux
donc il ya plusieurs clubs franciliens
qui participent à l'épreuve il ya
notamment vélizy mon team retenu clamart
plus tôt villeneuve la garenne créteil
et montgeron vigneux toutes les équipes
jouent vraiment je t'envoie leurs
meilleurs coureurs wheeler meilleurs
coureurs et là ce sont
les clubs franciliens très sensibilisés
sur le cyclisme sur piste
que ce soit chez les hommes chez les
dames avec par exemple 9 la garenne est
plutôt qu'ils possèdent de très bons
éléments féminins et ses clubs se sont
réunis pour organiser donc cette coupe
d'hiver avec le comité d'île de france
bien sûr
et puis le soutien technique du bureau
national vous parliez des miens clair il
y aura également d'autres têtes
d'affiché sur ce rendez vous oui daily
star de l'équipe de france des pistardes
eu les coudées de l'équipe de france et
notamment des pistards du pôle olympique
ce sont des jeunes pistards donc en
devenir avec dès qu'ils ont été
champions de france juniors voir
champion du monde juniors bryan et la
halle qui est qui a été le champion du
monde junior et c'est la jeune
révélation là qui a participé à deux
coupes de coupe du monde sera
vraisemblement l'a pas remis parmi les
qualifiés nos combien de coureurs pour
cette finale
alors nous attendons 150 coureurs donc
sur 17 catégories je vais sur les omnium
et pour la vitesse c'est donc la
deuxième édition c'est la deuxième
édition vous sentez une progression par
rapport au premier rendez vous oui il ya
un engouement parce que sur les quatre
manches
nous avons refusé beaucoup de pisteurs
qui voulaient s'inscrire mais dans
chaque catégorie c'est la réglementation
qui le veut nous sommes obligés de
limiter à 24 coureurs par catégories et
dans certaines catégories notamment chez
les cadets chez les chez les juniors et
chez les toutes catégories
bien sûr on aurait pu en prendre deux
fois trois fois plus et ça permet
également de mettre en valeur le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a reçu du handball je le
disais précédemment avec le match ici
paris contre des norvégiennes les
vipères ce kristiansand est-ce que ça
permet de remettre le vélo centre de ce
vélo de saint quentin en yvelines et
bien sûr il faut
le sait sa vocation première donc du
cyclisme sur piste et nous sommes très
envieux parce que samedi soir gare était
à 4000 spectateurs et nous espérons
avoir quatre mille spectateurs mais si
on en avait la moitié ce serait bien et
donc il faut rappeler que l'entrée est à
3 euros
et ce sera gratuit pour pour tous les
jeunes les jeunes des écoles de vélo
mais les jeunes des collèges et donc moi
je vous invite à découvrir un spectacle
de très grande qualité quelles que
soient les catégories le cyclisme sur
piste c'est toujours très spectaculaire
d'autant plus que nous aurons un beau
tournoi de vitesse devrait y avoir
également une tête d'affiché on peut le
dire hors compétition ça sera robert
marchand qui avait réalisé un record du
monde au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était en
janvier 2017
robert marchand 106 ans cette année
sortira de sa retraite pour venir
concourir à cette coupe d'hiver oui
l'invité d'honneur sera robert marchand
il tenait absolument à venir déjà
encouragé les jeunes mais aussi à faire
quelques tours de piste même si là il
arrête sa carrière entre guillemets à la
presse
il ne veut plus tentés de record mais il
pratique tous les jours tous les jours
il fait du vélo et dimanche bien sûr il
viendra à fait faire quelques tours et
puis au pour le grand le plaisir de
les jeunes et des moins jeunes étude de
tous les spectateurs lorsque robert
marchand se déplacent c'est toujours un
événement et vous êtes son coach
également vous habitez son coach pendant
les son record mais voilà pendant ces
deux records c'est trop facile pour
convaincre du coup voilà j'ai j'ai eu
l'honneur de deux coachs et robert
marchand et bien sûr c'est toujours avec
plaisir qu'il se rend au vélodrome et
puis partager cette passion avec les
jeunes merci à vous jean michel
richefort de passer sur ce plateau je
rappelle la finale de la coupe d'hiver
est programmée ce dimanche de 10h à 18h
vélotour nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines en termine ce magazine par un
rendez-vous si le 52e super bowl de ce
dimanche soir entre les patriots de la
nouvelle angleterre et les eagles de
philadelphie vous a donné envie de vous
intéresser au football américain au
niveau local les templiers d'elancourt
joue contre les spartiates d'amiens
complexe sportif europe un match qui
s'annonce spectaculaire les deux équipes
occupent les deux premières places de la
poule à de deuxième division la
rencontre est programmée ce samedi à 20
heures
c'est la fin 68 sport merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
un nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]